hey Ron I'm outtie sharp and I'm here is
my friend Abbi Langer I'm sorry
so we're back and you know we've done a
lot of these diet testings and we've had
a few doozies yeah and I say that like
the queen of the detox is our friend
Gweneth Paltrow more like frenemy I
would say oh hey oh here we are scouring
her goop a treasure trove of
misinformation as far as I'm concerned
only have a shower now also we took a
little look-see and we found that she
has a detox that she advocates wow
that's a shock I know weird like going
up in a detox oh so we decided that we'd
give it a little go d yeah we did it we
did it okay we did one day of the seven
because that would be not the I honestly
I have a life and I don't want to kill
my husband this week and so let's get to
it
Here I am about to start a day of
Gwyneth Paltrow's diet so here is the
first step the lemon water it tastes
like lemon water
nothing nothing here to see people hey
guys so I'm starting the day here with
my lemon water not exactly the most
filling food in the morning not sure how
I'm going to get to my workout but I'm
going to do my best
so bottoms up
let's do this
dead ahead and I at this point I was I
was hopeful I've I was feeling good it
was morning time look at the color my I
know you know it would get all up to
like normal human being
why are 3:00 in the morning so now I'm
on to the second part of the gwyneth
paltrow detox cleanse whatever it is and
it is herbal tea so it's not a suit on
this is there alright so I'm back for my
workout and it's on to meal number two
like us no food yet unfortunately but it
is tea time and I normally love to eat
but I'm starving because I have to eat
something after a workout and apparently
well thanks no so we're going to see how
this goes I'm starting to get really
concerned I look a little harassed here
I know kind of like I'm getting hungry
so I just finished my workout and I was
happily ravenous like look at me I look
like hell I look like death I mean I
love tea but like I mean any food for
god sake
I know it's for work after working I was
I was I was angry oh yeah yeah okay so
now we've gotten to the actual food part
of the detox and it's a blueberry almond
smoothie that I made she's like Bluebird
she's so bad
oh I'm so excited
first actual food of the day even though
it's not actually chewable it's a liquid
it's a liquid meal but I'm still so
psyched so this is my blueberry Anand
smoothie basically some frozen
blueberries on the milk and a bunch of
weird powders like greens and protein
powder so not normally would I be
excited about this but in this case I'm
starving so I'm very very enthusiastic
at this point so it's gross but it's
gonna have to do ah oh look at me and I
look like a blueberry grass clipping it
was like a freshly cut lawn it was about
the greens in there with the blueberry
what a waste of blueberries okay guys so
next a little mini snack is my coconut
water I hate coconut water full
disclosure but I'm going to drink it
because today I'm really hungry and I
need all the nourishment calories that I
can possibly get so that my stomach does
not eat itself there's a lot of fake
smiling on this diet under no other
circumstances what I drink this my lunch
today consists of little gem lettuce
which I've substituted with just plain
romaine lettuce because gwyneth like
little gem is $6 as well one source of
$6 on lettuce this is definitely a detox
for rich people and quarter of an
avocado and this vile eight ingredient
carrot ginger dressing that is
absolutely disgusting I don't know how
it's going to go but I don't care cuz
I'm starving I'm gonna put a little bit
of this on my greens here and on this
plate it looks kind of like a baby ate
mac and cheese and then puked all over a
bowl of greens like it's not appetizing
again I'm starving
I was so disappointed because I was like
really looking forward to real soon
glass you know and then this was it this
is so low in calories this is basically
a starvation diet is not hey I mean ah B
we are in sync girl are we're starving
and in sync
Texas does so snack time on goop means
apparently a handful of sunflower seeds
and pumpkin seeds and I'm not sure if
one of us hands are big as mine but I'm
so hungry I'm planning on like getting
the most colossal hand full ever like
I'm maybe going to use my husband's hand
as a gauge because it's bigger than mine
and I think I need like all the pumpkin
seeds and sunflower seeds because I'm
starving
I've literally had a smoothie some tea
some goddamn coconut water and a salad
with the grossest friggin dressing I've
ever had in my life like I almost rather
had nothing so I'm going to enjoy these
goddamn seeds I'm going to have all them
I might go get the bag afterwards for
another handful because that's the point
I'm at right now I don't think he's a
ramp I'm still willing to eat them all
I was hangry can you not see the rage in
my eyes I was like you remember how
angry happen oh I was like get me some
skin sleep bye anyway I was like but I
think my seeds had gone rancid I know
that's a desperate like help me I'm not
good to me god I warned you but that
that's the desperation that you get you
take a look alright
I'm so hungry I could nah my own arm off
this is ridiculous this is not going to
make you lose weight for any appreciable
amount of time like just change your
eating habits for the better you don't
just starve yourself and it's not
detoxing anything it's
just idiocy anyways right here I have my
broccoli arugula soup which I mean I
don't even want to eat this it's
disgusting it makes me sad I don't feel
healthier I just feel like deprived and
stupid for doing this so I've made this
broccoli and a regular soup here which
honestly it's not soup
it's just basically a warm smoothie so I
would just prefer if going to call it
like it is because honestly if pureed
broccoli arugula and water and lemon I
mean it's it's not soup it's not it was
like a wet fart smoothie that's a better
life let me yeah not like firm okay
might have a smelly fart I propped it in
the fridge the fridge smells like first
like where's the smell all the time
yes dude it doesn't stink but let me
tell you on a diet like this you are
going to be smelly yes when it does not
fart rainbows and sparkles oh oh
aquitine ridiculous Wow and what's up at
the geriatric hour like 6 p.m. for
dinner and then that said last time you
get to eat okay so I just put myself to
bed at like 7:00 because I was just
going to be thinking about food the
whole thing and her likes partner mmm I
dreamt I was like I was like the taste
tester at Cheesecake Factory like I had
a horrible night and I mean looking back
on the day I don't think I felt any
clear-headed or oh I don't feel that
what's in a word that's how you know you
lose your mind only when basically you
become really shitty it really big I was
I was abnormal yeah and this was like to
the next level oh yeah I know
and so I just got to say you don't make
friends on goups detox no doesn't you
shouldn't no no be friends with someone
who does this definitely never know so
in conclusion I would say this is not a
diet that you need to be going on it
doesn't make any sense the rest of the
week is just as bad it's basically just
a variation
that a lot of TV a lot of water a lot of
putrid smoothie by having feet long
specialists our doctor yeah yeah yeah
don't guys you don't need a detox
specialist you don't need any kind of
detox because your body is a detox
specialist well Abby I think we did that
one justice as much justice as I don't
think I need to do that no I never want
to do that again so I hope you enjoyed
watching us torture ourselves on one day
of goofy talk if you did be sure to give
it a thumbs up leave us a comment below
with what you want us to try next
whatever creates diets you find the
internet will give them a little cozy
possibly and of course subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]